[Music]
on this saturday night deadly ontario
storm
[Music]
the trail of destruction left behind by
surprise extreme weather in central
canada
abortion ban the people of oklahoma are
going to suffer and that blood will be
on our hands lawmakers in oklahoma pass
america's most restrictive abortion bill
what this means for women's rights
across the country
travel chaos people are pissed off
frustrations boiling over as thousands
of canadians scramble to jet away they
should hire more people or figure it out
and food spending woes food inflation is
probably the biggest issue affecting
households right now with prices soaring
canadians turn to meal kits but do they
actually save you money
global national
reporting tonight tracy tong
[Music]
good evening and thank you for joining
us we begin with breaking news out of
the greater toronto area where a woman
in her 70s has died after being struck
by a falling tree during a wild
thunderstorm this afternoon
i believe she was alone when she was
walking
during the storm and
you know who's to know that this is
something that's going to happen
this is just an absolute about an hour
away
about an hour away south of kitchener
ontario provincial police say a second
person also died in the storm after a
tree fell on a camping trailer
wind gusts of more than 130 kilometers
an hour damaged homes knocked down trees
and power lines
thousands of power outages were reported
nickel-sized hail was also seen falling
across the region
environment canada says there have been
no official reports of a tornado but
officials are still gathering data
one of the hardest hit areas by this
storm is about an hour northeast of
toronto
officials in the township of uxbridge in
the region of durham have now declared a
local state of emergency
after the storm left significant damage
in its wake our morgan campbell is there
tonight
pam lawson is lucky to be alive she
lives in what's left of this apartment
in uxbridge
it just started and the door pushed me
back so i
i was
against the wall and the roof went the
windows went
it was just
and it
i don't know how long it lasted but it
seemed a long time the 55 year old is
one of many without a home to go to
todd bogarts also lives in the apartment
building this is his truck it looks like
it was picked up and thrown on its side
it's like a frigging war zone like it's
right from here right through to the
other side of the tin mill that's
exactly what it looks like
across the road at the historic railway
station much of the building and cars
were destroyed this was their opening
day and the volunteer-led organization
was already on the brink of collapse two
of our staff were here and taking
shelter in one of the trailers
and it was the only thing that didn't
get destroyed on our property in nearby
york region musselman's lake was hit
hard by the storm many downed trees and
power lines littered major arteries
causing road closures we caught wayne
steele as he rushed home to check on his
house i heard some of my roof blew off i
just came from mossport there's trailers
flipped over with trucks on their side
and freaked me out i got a call from a
buddy of mine saying i better get home
but back here in uxbridge those who live
here are resilient and they say they
will work to rebuild
i wouldn't want to go through it again
i'll tell you morgan campbell global
news oxbridge
to the united states now where the most
restrictive abortion bill in america has
been passed by lawmakers in oklahoma all
that's left is the governor's signature
and he has promised to sign it
the bill prohibits abortions from the
moment of fertilization
and relies on lawsuits from private
citizens to enforce it its only
exceptions are for medical emergencies
or in cases of sexual assault or incest
pro-choice advocates are warning of dire
consequences for thousands of women as
abortion clinics are already closing
their doors
jennifer johnson has the latest
oklahoma lawmakers have now
overwhelmingly passed the nation's
strictest abortion bill the vote wasn't
even close 73-16
the state's republican governor running
for re-election is expected to sign it
into law early next week we believe life
begins at conception and we're going to
protect life in oklahoma the bill
provides only two exceptions allowing
abortions to save the life of a pregnant
woman or if the pregnancy was the result
of rape or incest that's been reported
to law enforcement the abortion clinics
in the state are already closing the
people of oklahoma are going to suffer
and that blood will be on our hands some
pregnant women in texas had been coming
to oklahoma seeking the procedure after
their state banned abortions after six
weeks but not anymore the white house is
denouncing the bill it's outrageous and
it's just the latest in a series of
extreme laws
around the country
at least 12 states in the u.s have
so-called trigger laws that will
immediately ban or greatly restrict
abortions if the supreme court overturns
roe v wade that could happen as early as
next month
pro-choice protests have erupted around
the country since news of the high
court's possible decision was leaked
without the freedom to choose
women will die
and families will suffer child advocates
warn it will be the newborn babies who
will suffer statistics show over half of
the 4 thousand women in oklahoma seeking
abortions each year are impoverished
when these children are born into
poverty when they suffer abuse neglect
separation of a parent whether it's
incarceration or divorce
the health care concerns and the mental
trauma which would require counseling
the numbers are going to go up
pro-choice advocates say abortion rights
guaranteed in the u.s for almost 50
years are rapidly disappearing the
conservative majority supreme court has
indicated it wants states to determine
abortion laws and many conservative
states are welcoming that opportunity
jennifer johnson global news washington
in quebec demonstrators once again took
to the streets this weekend to protest
bill 96 the province's controversial
language legislation
a group of ganaway first nation students
led a protest which made its way into
montreal this morning but premier
francois lego's government is set to
enact the legislation in the coming days
dan spector speaks to those who hope
changes are made before it becomes law
[Applause]
it sparked anger protests and fear
quebec's new french language protection
law has divided the province bill 96 is
stirring up
old tensions and old
old quarrels it's going to be a hassle
stefan zupre runs a small furniture
manufacturing company in montreal
he understands the need to protect
french but feels the new law is bad for
business it's going to directly affect
our operations
bill 96 brings in new requirements for
small businesses to prove they are
functioning in french
large companies already need to do this
but now smaller enterprises dealing with
worker shortages and rising costs will
need to shift their focus to adherence
that means pages of paperwork hiring
consultants making sure all computer
software is in french employees here
come from over a dozen countries there
will be misunderstanding there will be
problems with orders some estimate
dozens of hours and millions of dollars
lost at businesses across the province
it is the worst thing to do to increase
red tape for small museum-sized business
in quebec legal experts say thanks to
the notwithstanding clause the
government will be able to seize
documents without a warrant to make sure
companies are working in french the
normal basis for challenging
unreasonable searches are being pushed
aside health care professionals also
have deep concerns for patients not
comfortable in french what it says is
that it will be forbidden
for public service employees to use
languages other than french long-time
anglophone residents will retain the
right to be cared for in their mother
tongue but recent immigrants will only
have six months before needing to deal
with the state in french this will
create
problems possible medical errors will
build 96 the government went on the
offensive in recent days to allay fears
what
people are unfiltered to have is to have
her health services in their own
language
but it didn't help
unless we see it in writing
that the profession of health care will
be exempt from the restrictions and the
punitive measures
that are indicated in this bill we are
not satisfied with its majority
government quebec will be able to pass
the bill before the spring national
assembly session ends the hope is that
it isn't applied the way many fear it
will be dan specter global news montreal
well we have heard for months how
service canada locations have been
inundated with canadians clamoring to
renew passports but it's now may and the
lineups are just as long as mike derlay
reports speeding up the process is not
as simple as hiring more staff
so right now it's not going to happen
for you guys i'm sorry with frustrations
at a boil and information on service
canada's own website unreliable
here's your liability frontline staff at
this surrey bc location summed up the
state of the passport backlog it's like
a hit
it's like
people are pissed off they're just
they're not understanding why there's no
walk-ins when there's so many empty
chairs inside with online appointments
scarce people have resorted to lining up
for long hours only to be turned away
and it's not just service canada
the offices for the nexus trusted
traveler program in toronto were closed
two years ago and have yet to reopen
even though the u.s program is fully
operational yeah we are a victim of the
you know they should hire more people or
figure it out according to travel
experts the federal government simply
wasn't prepared for over 500 000
passport applications to be filed in
march and april that type of number is
typically
unprecedented even in pre-pandemic era
in in the springtime but again you have
the expiration of passports the release
of pent-up energy the release of travel
restrictions
all accumulating into like a perfect
storm of people clamoring for
information the government said in part
service canada has hired 600 new
employees and opened more dedicated
passport intake counters
however the union says its members need
12 weeks of training before they're
qualified to authorize a new passport so
for the foreseeable future we may have
to get used to empty service canada
locations you just have to keep on time
no matter how frustrating it is
mike trolley global news toronto
well after years of delaying canada is
joining its five eyes allies in banning
huawei from this country's
telecommunications network
ottawa declared the chinese tech giants
infrastructure a threat to national
security but the decision came suddenly
on thursday with no reason given for the
timing so why did it take so long this
week on the west block mercedes
stephenson sits down with canada's
public safety minister to find out
mercedes
tracy many thought the government
delayed making a decision to protect the
two michaels who were arbitrarily
detained by beijing for more than a
thousand days but if so why did it take
the government nearly eight months to
announce a decision after they came home
we put those questions to public safety
minister marco mendicino who flat out
denied the long-standing belief that the
timeline or decision were connected to
the detention of the two michaels
well i want to make sure that we
decouple the situation with the two
michaels and we're obviously very
pleased that they were released with the
review of these two particular actors
and the telecommunications there's no
relationship between the timing there no
there's not huawei and another
chinese-owned telecom zte are both
barred from not just canada's 5g
expansion but already existing 4g
infrastructure the government says they
consider these companies high-risk
vendors and can't take part in an
industry that has national security
implications while the political
decision sends a strong signal to
beijing there are questions about what
else the government will do to shore up
canada's cyber security from foreign
spying and to protect critical
industries in canada from beijing
mendicino says the trudeau government is
planning to introduce legislation that
will help to protect canadian national
security interests in other industries
so whether we're talking about the
financial sector um you know our natural
resources sector you know essentially uh
the the vital parts and organs of our
economy we need to make sure that we're
protecting them and making sure that
we're updating our legislative tools to
do just that as for when these tools
will be in place the minister says the
government plans to act quickly but
would not provide an exact timeline all
this comes as the trudeau government has
been changing tact on how it deals with
beijing to take a tougher stance a
significant change in strategy that was
first telegraphed by the prime minister
in an interview with global news at
christmas we've been competing and china
has been from time to time very cleverly
playing us off each other in a in an
open market competitive way
we need to do a better job of working
together and standing strong so that
china can't you know play the angles and
divide us one against the other you can
catch our full interview with the
minister tomorrow on the west walk tracy
all right our mercedes stevenson
reporting from ottawa thank you
coming up the latest on cases of monkey
pox here in canada stay with us
toronto is investigating its first
suspected case of monkey pox in a man
who had recent contact with someone who
traveled to montreal this comes after
three more cases were confirmed in
quebec bringing the total in that
province to five the public health
agency of canada says it is still
investigating about two dozen other
suspected cases of the rare disease
earlier on friday chief public health
officer dr teresa tam said it's unclear
how widespread the disease has become in
this country
but stressed the risk to the public is
low
a common childhood virus called
adenovirus is now the leading hypothesis
for recent cases of severe hepatitis in
children that have led to at least six
deaths in the u.s
the cdc says it is investigating whether
180 cases identified since last october
represent an actual increase or whether
an existing pattern has been found
through improved detection
around half of the children diagnosed
recently also had adenovirus which
causes the common cold but the exact
cause of the illness is still under
investigation
there have also been 10 cases recorded
in canada
ahead on global national meal kits can
save food waste but are they saving you
any money
a state of local emergency was declared
in manitoba's white shell provincial
park last night as officials say rising
water levels posed a significant threat
to public safety the batula lake area
near the ontario border has been
evacuated with residents in the
surrounding areas being told to be ready
to leave at a moment's notice
well food inflation is at its worst in
four decades with prices up nearly 10
percent in the past year that has
prompted some households to turn to meal
kits as a way to manage costs and reduce
waste but azan gaviola explains in the
second story of our sticker shock series
it won't save you money
take this couple of peppers toronto
resident janie gandhi cooks at home a
lot but she finds the amount spent to
feed her family of four including two
active children shocking i just feel
terribly sad saying the numbers but it's
around 400 to 500 a week when it comes
to groceries every other week or so they
opt for meal kits it costs more but the
time saved is valuable they definitely
come in from the point of view of saving
time because it takes the whole pain out
of the whole cooking process of what's
the ingredient that i need how much
quantity i need and what am i cooking
today according to research by dalhousie
university people flocked to meal kits
at the start of the pandemic causing
canadian sales to peak at 1.6 million
dollars in the first six months but the
easing of covid restrictions and the
amount of packaging that comes with most
meal kit services plus sticker shock
have given many households food for
thought food inflation is probably the
biggest issue affecting households right
now
and that meal cuts tend to be priced
quite high eight to thirteen dollars on
average per meal per person global news
averaged out the cost per serving of
three leading meal kit companies a
family of four can expect to pay about
ten dollars per serving the cost per
serving for a household of two though
nearly twelve dollars inflation is
expected to push up the total food spend
for a typical family of four to more
than fourteen thousand seven hundred and
sixty dollars this year that's an
increase of nearly a thousand dollars
from twenty twenty one personal finance
expert rubina ahmed hawk says shopping
with a list can save you more than
twenty percent
before you leave make a plan of what
you're going to buy according to what's
on sale and buy only what you need with
smaller frequent trips
for this household meal kits are also a
new culinary adventure they're willing
to pay a premium for once in a while
introduce something new experiment
something new that i'm not used to and
have the whole family involved into just
a basic cooking process ann gaviola
global news toronto
next cheers to the return of a beloved
west coast wine festival
wine lovers are the toast of vancouver's
waterfront with the return of the
international wine festival following a
covet 19 hiatus as paul johnson reports
many bc wineries were able to turn to
local enthusiasts in order to stay in
business
it's great to be back in the room again
pouring samples of their signature
aromatic white blends evan saunders can
tell you it's been a long haul since
march 2020. panic like everybody else to
start with for bc's wineries the early
pandemic saw both their restaurant
customers and business at their tasting
rooms disappear simultaneously
no one was sure what the future would be
or if they would be in it and everybody
putting their heads together and seeing
what we could do to survive essentially
but they did
on day one of the return of the
vancouver international wine festival bc
wineries make up 40 out of 100
exhibitors and it turns out their secret
to survival was other british colombians
who started ordering wine directly from
them in numbers that surprised even the
winemakers it just exploded we'd be
loading pallets onto trucks and seeing
pallets from other wineries all around
us going out as well the wine world is
back after missing last year the
festival is back with wines from 13
countries and the opportunity for that
personal experience it's not just about
tasting wine or getting a sample it's
the fact that when you taste wine you
get to look the owner the wine maker in
the eye and ask them questions and find
out the story behind the wines in that
glass looking forward bc's wineries hope
to restore that experience factor even
more asuyas's bordertown vineyards has a
popular cabernet franc but on top of the
health restrictions last summer saw them
dealing with wildfire smoke at their
tasting room heading into this summer
the feeling couldn't be more different
it's smile time everybody's you know a
little more relaxed now in vancouver
paul johnson global news
tonight's your canada are the tulips in
ottawa we love seeing your canada so
please keep sending your photos to
viewers at
globalnational.com thanks so much for
watching i'll see you here again
tomorrow good night